at this altitude I can run flat-out for
my hands hello boys and girls ladies and
gentlemen this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show this episode will feature
some of my favorite advice and profiles
from tribe of mentors thousands of you
have asked for years for the audio book
versions of tools of titans and tribal
mentors and they are now both finally
available at audible.com slash
ferrus today's episode will focus on my
first chapter in tribe of mentors as
well as profiles of navarre avacado
Susan Cain and Yuval Noah Harari
just a few notes on the format before we
dive in I recorded the introduction
myself and selected three fantastic
top-ranked narrators to handle the rest
the short BIOS which you'll hear at the
beginning of each profile are read by
Clio Griffith ray Porter reads my words
as well as those of the male guests the
words of female guests are performed by
Torres Plummer Trebek mentors is the
ultimate choose your own adventure book
it's a compilation of tools tactics and
habits from more than 100 of the world's
top performers from iconic entrepreneurs
to elite athletes from artists to
billionaire investors they're short
profiles can help you answer some of
life's most challenging questions
achieve extraordinary results and
hopefully transform your life as they
have mine really happy with how this
book turned out and the universe helped
me to pull off some miracles in traffic
mentors with guests like Ben Stiller
Temple Grandin ayaan Hirsi Ali you've
all know her Ari will you hear in this
episode Arianna Huffington Marc Benioff
Terry Crews Dan Gable and many many more
it includes a lot of the people I grew
up viewing his idols or demigods so
thanks for that universe and if you only
get one thing out of this book let it be
this in a world where nobody really
knows anything you have the incredible
freedom to continually reinvent yourself
and forge new paths no matter how
strange so embrace your weird self
there's no one right answer only better
questions for you I wish you luck as you
four
your own path please enjoy this episode
and if you'd like to listen to the 100
plus profiles outside of these examples
from tribe of mentors just check out
audible.com forward slash Faris to all
of my companions on the path may you be
a force for good in this world and see
the same in yourselves and remember as
Rumi once wrote what you seek is seeking
you introduction the only true voyage
would be not to travel through a hundred
different lands with the same pair of
eyes but to see the same land through a
hundred different pairs of eyes Marcel
Proust Albert grunted do you know what
happens to lads who ask too many
questions
Mort thought for a moment no he said
eventually what there was silence then
Albert straightened up and said damned
if I know
probably they get answers and serves him
right terry pratchett in Mort to explain
why I wrote this book I really need to
start with when 2017 was an unusual year
for me the first six months were a slow
simmer and then within a matter of weeks
I turned 40 my first book 4-hour
workweek had its tenth anniversary
several people in my circle of friends
died and I stepped onstage to explain
how I narrowly avoided committing
suicide in college truth be told I never
thought I'd make it to 40 my first book
was rejected 27 times by publishers the
things that worked out weren't supposed
to work so I realized on my birthday I
had no plan for after 40 as often
happens at Forks in the paths college
graduation quarter life crisis midlife
crisis kids leaving home retirement and
so on questions started to bubble to the
surface where my goals actually my own
or simply what I thought I should want
how much of life had I missed from under
planning or over planning
how could I be kinder to myself how
could I better say no to the noise to
better say yes to the adventures I
craved how could I best reassess my life
my priority
my view of the world my place in the
world and my trajectory through the
world so many things all the things one
morning I wrote down the questions as
they came hoping for a glimmer of
clarity instead I felt a wave of anxiety
the list was overwhelming noticing that
I was holding my breath I paused and
took my eyes off the paper then I did as
I often do whether considering a
business decision personal relationship
or otherwise I asked myself the one
question that helps answer many others
what would this look like if it were
easy this could be anything that morning
it was answering a laundry list of big
questions what would this look like if
it were easy is such a lovely and
deceptively leveraged question it's easy
to convince yourself that things need to
be hard that if you're not red lining
you're not trying hard enough
this leads us to look for paths of most
resistance often creating unnecessary
hardship in the process but what happens
if we frame things in terms of elegance
instead of strain sometimes we find
incredible results with ease instead of
stress sometimes we solve the problem by
completely reframing it in that morning
by journaling on this question what
would this look like if it were easy in
longhand an idea presented itself 99% of
the page was useless but there is one
seed of a possibility what if I
assembled a tribe of mentors to help me
more specifically what if I asked more
than a hundred brilliant people the very
questions I wanted to answer for myself
or somehow got them to guide me in the
right direction when at work I had no
idea but I did know one thing if the
easy approach failed the unending labor
and the salt mines approach was always
waiting in the wings pain is never out
of season if you go shopping for it so
why not spend a week test driving the
path of least resistance and so it began
first I scribbled down a list of dream
interviewees which started as one-page
and quickly became 10 it had to be a
list with no limitations no one too big
two out of reach or too hard to find
could I get the Dalai Lama the
incredible Temple Grandin my personal
white whale author Neil Gaiman or ayaan
Hirsi Ali I wrote out the most ambitious
eclectic unusual list possible next I
needed to create an incentive to
encourage people to respond so I worked
on a book deal B in my book might work
from the outset I told my publisher that
also might not work and that I'd return
the advance if so then I started
pitching my little heart out I sent an
identical set of eleven questions to
some of the most successful wildly
varied and well-known people on the
planet with answer your favorite three
to five questions or more if the spirit
moves you after hitting send dozens of
times I clutched my hands to my excited
writers chest with bated breath to which
the universe replied with silence
crickets for 12 to 24 hours nothing not
a creature was stirring not even a mouse
and then there was a faint trickle
through the ether a whisper of curiosity
and a handful of clarifying questions
some polite the clients followed and
then came the torrent nearly all of the
people I reached out to our busy beyond
belief and I expected I would get short
rushed responses from a few of them at
best what I got back instead were some
of the most thoughtful answers I'd ever
received
whether on paper in person or otherwise
in the end there are more than 100
respondents granted the so-called easy
path took thousands of back-and-forth
emails and Twitter direct messages
hundreds of phone calls many marathons
on a treadmill desk and more than a few
bottles of wine during late-night
writing sessions but it worked did it
always work no I didn't get the Dalai
Lama this time and at least half the
people in my list didn't respond or
decline the invitation but it worked
enough to matter and that is what
matters in cases where the outreach
worked the questions did all the heavy
lifting eight of the questions were fine
tuned rapid-fire questions from my
podcast the Tim Ferriss show the first
business interview podcast to pass 100
million downloads now
400 to 500 million downloads these
questions have been refined over more
than 400 interviews with guests such as
actor musician Jamie Foxx General
Stanley McChrystal and writer
Maria Popova I knew that these questions
worked that interviewees generally liked
them and that they could help me in my
own life
the remaining three questions were new
additions that I hoped would solve some
of my most chronic problems before
taking them into the wild I tested
vetted and wordsmith them with friends
who were world-class performers in their
own right the older I get the more time
I spend as a percentage of each day on
crafting better questions in my
experience going from 1x to 10x from 10
X to 100 X and from 100 X to when Lady
Luck really smiles 1000 X returns in
various areas has been a product of
better questions John Dewey's dictum
that a problem well put is half salt
applies life punishes the vague wish and
rewards the specific ask after all
conscious thinking is largely asking and
answering questions in your own head if
you want confusion and heartache ask
vague questions if you want uncommon
clarity and results ask uncommonly clear
questions fortunately this is the skill
you can develop no book can give you all
the answers but this book can train you
to ask better questions Milan Kundera
author of The Unbearable Lightness of
being has said that the stupidity of
people comes from having an answer for
everything
the wisdom of the novel comes from
having a question for everything
substitute master learner for novel and
you have my philosophy of life often all
that stands between you and what you
want is a better set of questions now
I'll list the 11 questions I chose for
this book it's important to listen to
the full questions and the explanations
as I shorten them throughout the rest of
the book special thanks to Brian
Koppelman Amelia Boone Chase Jarvis and
of all rob Cohn and others for their
hugely helpful feedback first let us
take a quick pass of the 11 questions
some of them might seem trite or useless
at first
but low things are not always what they
appear number one what is the book or
books you've given most as a gift and
why or what are one two three books that
have greatly influenced your life number
two what purchase of $100 or less has
most positively impacted your life in
the last six months or in recent memory
my readers love specifics like Brandon
model where you found it etc number
three how is a failure or a parent
failure set you up for later success do
you have a favorite failure of yours
number four if you could have a gigantic
billboard anywhere with anything on it
metaphorically speaking getting a
message out to millions or billions of
people what would it say and why it
could be a few words or a paragraph if
helpful it can be someone else's quote
are there any quotes you think of often
or live your life by number five what is
one of the best or most worthwhile
investments you've ever made could be an
investment of money time energy etc
number six what is an unusual habit or
an absurd thing that you love number
seven in the last five years
what new belief behavior or habit has
most improved your life number eight
what advice would you give to a smart
driven college student about to enter
the so-called real world what advice
should they ignore number nine what are
bad recommendations you hear in your
profession or area of expertise number
ten in the last five years what have you
become better at saying no to
distractions invitations etc what new
realizations and or approaches helped
any other tips number eleven when you
feel overwhelmed or unfocused or have
lost your focus temporarily what do you
do if helpful what questions do you ask
yourself now let's take a look at each
of these questions and I'll explain why
they appear to work you might ask why
should I care I'm not an interviewer to
that my response is simple if you want
to build or
Oster a world-class Network you'd need
to interact in a way that earns it all
of these points will help for instance I
spent weeks testing the order of
questions for optimal responses
to me proper sequencing is the secret
sauce whether you're trying to learn a
new language in 8 to 12 weeks overcome a
lifelong fear of swimming as I did or
pick the brain of a potential mentor
over coffee good questions in the wrong
order get bad responses conversely you
can punch well above your weight class
by thinking about sequencing as most
people don't
for example the Billboard question is
one of my podcast listener end guest
favorites but it's heavy it stumps or
intimidates a lot of people I didn't
want to scare busy people off who might
opt out with a quick sorry time I just
don't have bandwidth for this right now
so what to do easy let them warm up with
lightweight questions for example most
gifted books purchase up under $100
which are less abstract and more
concrete in the following descriptions
my explanations get shorter towards the
end of the 11 questions as many of the
points carry over or apply to all of
them number 1 what is the book or books
you've given most as a gift and why or
what are one two three books that have
greatly influenced your life what's your
favorite book seems like a good question
so innocent so simple in practice it's
terrible the people I interview over at
hundreds or thousands of books so it's a
labor-intensive question for them and
they rightly worry about picking a
favorite which then gets quoted and put
in articles Wikipedia etc most gifted is
lower risk and easier search query in
other words easier to recall and implies
benefits for a broader spectrum of
people which the idiosyncratic favorite
does not for the curious and impatient
among you here are a few books of many
that came up a lot in this book man's
search for meaning by victory Frankel
the rational optimist by Matt Ridley the
better angels of our nature by Steven
Pinker sapiens by Yuval Noah Harari poor
Charlie's Almanac by Charlie Munger if
you'd like to see all of
the recommended books in one place
including a list of the top 20 most
recommended from this book and tools of
titans my previous book you can find all
the goodies at tim dot blog forward
slash book list number two what purchase
of one hundred dollars or less has most
positively impacted your life in the
last six months or in recent memory my
fans love specifics like brandon model
where you found it etc this might seem
like a throw away but it isn't it
provides an easy entry point for busy
interviewees while providing readers
with something immediately actionable
the deeper questions elicit more
profound answers but profundity is the
fiber of knowledge requires intensive
digestion to keep marching forward in
the meanwhile humans yours truly
included need short term rewards in this
book I accomplished that with questions
that provide tangible easy and often fun
answers Scooby Snacks for your hard
working salt you want to think of it
that way to get the heavier lifting done
these breathers are important number
three how has a failure or apparent
failure set you up for later success do
you have a favorite failure of yours
this one is particularly important to me
as I wrote in tools of titans the super
heroes you have in your mind idols icons
elite athletes billionaires etc are
nearly all walking flaws who've
maximized one or two strengths humans
are imperfect creatures you don't
succeed because you have no weaknesses
you succeed because you find your unique
strengths and focus on developing habits
around them everyone is fighting a
battle and has fought battles you know
nothing about the heroes in this book
are no different everyone struggles
number four if you could have one
gigantic billboard anywhere with
anything on it metaphorically speaking
getting a message out to millions or
billions of people what would it say and
why it could be a few words or a
paragraph if helpful it can be someone
else's quote are there any quotes you
think of often or live your life by this
one's pretty self-explanatory so I'll
skip the commentary for would-be
interviewers though the
if helpful portion is often critical for
getting good answers number five what is
one of the best or most worthwhile
investments you've ever made could be an
investment of money time energy etc this
is also self explanatory or so it seems
with questions like this in the next I
found it productive to give interviewees
a real-world answer an example in a live
interview it buys them time to think and
in text say an email it gives them a
template for this question for instance
I gave everyone the following sample
answer from Amelia Boone one of the
world's top endurance athletes sponsored
by big brands and four-time world
champion in obstacle course racing OCR
in 2011 i shelled out four hundred and
fifty dollars to participate in the
first world's toughest Mudder a brand
new 24 hour obstacle race saddled with
law school debt it was a big expenditure
for me and I had no business thinking I
could even complete the race let alone
compete in it but I ended up being one
of eleven finishers out of a thousand
participants of that race and it altered
the course of my life leading to my
career in obstacle racing and multiple
world championships had I not plunked
down the cash for that entry fee none of
that would have happened number six what
is an unusual habit or an absurd thing
that you love I was first asked this
when interviewed by my friend Chris
young scientist co-author of modernist
cuisine and CEO of chefsteps
search Jewel sous-vide for more on that
before responding and while sitting on
stage at the Town Hall in Seattle I said
ooh that's a good question
I'm gonna steal that so I did this
question has deeper implications than
you might expect answers prove a number
of helpful things number one everyone is
crazy so you're not alone number two if
you want more OCD like behaviors my
interviewees are happy to help and three
corollary to number one so-called normal
people are just crazy people you don't
know well enough if you think you're
uniquely neurotic I hate to deliver the
news but every human is Woody Allen in
some part of their life here's the
sample answer I gave for this question
taken from a live interview
and slightly edited for length sample
answer from Cheryl Strayed best-selling
author of wild here's my whole theory of
the sandwich every bite should be as
much like the previous bite as possible
do you follow if there's a clump of
Tomatoes here but then there's hummus
everything has to be as uniform as
possible so any sandwich I'm ever given
I open it up and I immediately
completely rearrange the sandwich number
seven in the last five years
what new belief behavior or habit has
most improved your life this is short
effective and not particularly nuanced
it had particular application to my
midlife reassessment and quite frankly
I'm surprised I don't hear questions
like this more often
number eight what advice would you give
to a smart driven college student about
to enter the real world what advice
should they ignore the second ignore sub
question is essential we're prone to
asking what should I do but less prone
to asking what shouldn't I do since what
we don't do determines what we can do I
like asking about not to do lists number
nine what are bad recommendations you
hear in your profession or area of
expertise this is a close cousin of the
previous question many problems of
focusing are best solved by defining
what to ignore number 10 in the last
five years what have you become better
at saying no to distractions invitations
etc what new realizations and or
approaches have helped any other tips
saying yes is easy saying no is hard
I wanted help with the ladder as did
many of the people in this book and some
answers really delivered the goods
number eleven when you feel overwhelmed
or unfocused or have lost your focus
temporarily what do you do if helpful
what questions do you ask yourself if
your mind is Beach bawling that's a nerd
eMac reference to when a computer
freezes
nothing else matters much until that is
resolved once again the secondary if
helpful question is often critical since
any greatness in this book is from other
people I feel very comfortable
that no matter where you are in life you
will love some of what is here in the
same breath no matter how much I cry and
pout you will find some of what's inside
boring useless or seemingly stupid out
of roughly 140 profiles I expect you to
like 70 love 35 and have your life
changed by perhaps 17 amusingly the 70
you dislike will be precisely the 70
someone else needs life would be boring
if we all followed exactly the same
rules and you will want to pick and
choose the more surprising part of all
of this is tribe of mentors changes with
you as time passes and life unfolds
things you initially swatted away like a
distraction can reveal depth and become
unimaginably important that cliche you
ignored like a throwaway fortune cookie
suddenly it makes sense and moves
mountains
conversely things you initially found
enlightening might have run their course
like a wonderful highschool coach who
needs to hand you off to a college coach
for you to reach the next level there's
no expiration date on the advice in this
book is there's no uniformity in the
following hours you'll hear advice from
30-something Vonda Keynes and seasoned
veterans in their 60s and 70s the hope
is that each time you listen to this
book not unlike with the eaching or
daodejing something new will grab you
shake your perception of reality
illuminate your follies confirm your
intuitions or correct your course that
all-important one degree the entire
spectrum of human emotion and experience
can be found in this book from hilarious
to heart-wrenching from failure to
success and from life to death may you
welcome it all on my coffee table at
home I have a piece of driftwood its
sole purpose is to display a quote by
Anais Nin which I see every day life
shrinks or expands in proportion to
one's courage it's a short reminder that
success can usually be measured by the
number of uncomfortable conversations we
are willing to have and by the number of
uncomfortable actions we are willing to
take the most fulfilled and effective
people I know world-famous creatives
billionaires thought leaders so on and
so forth look at their life's journey as
perhaps 25% finding themselves and 75%
creating themselves
this book is not intended to be a
passive experience it's intended to be a
call to action you are the author of
your own life and it's never too late to
replace the stories you tell yourself
and the world it's never too late to
begin a new chapter add a surprise twist
or change genre z' entirely what would
it look like if it were easy
here's to picking up the pen with a
smile big things are coming self-esteem
is just the reputation that you have
with yourself you'll always know navall
rava khat twitter at navall startup boy
calm navall rava khat is the CEO and
co-founder of angellist he previously
co-founded vast calm and opinions calm
which went public as part of shopping
calm he is an active angel investor and
has invested in more than 100 companies
including many unicorn mega successes
his deals include Twitter uber Yammer
post mates wish thumbtack and open DNS
in recent years he is the person I call
most for start-up related advice what is
the book or books you've given most as a
gift and why or what are one two three
books that have greatly influenced your
life total freedom by Jiddu Krishnamurti
a rationalist guide to the perils of the
human mind the spiritual book that I
keep returning to sapiens by you've all
know aa Harare a history of the human
species with observations frameworks and
mental models that will have you looking
at history in your fellow humans
differently everything by Matt Ridley
matt is a scientist optimist and forward
thinker genome the Red Queen the origins
of virtue the rational optimist they're
all great how has a failure or apparent
failure set you up for later success do
you have a favorite failure of yours
suffering
is a moment of clarity when you can no
longer deny the truth of a situation and
are forced into uncomfortable change I'm
lucky that I didn't get everything I
wanted in my life or I'd be happy with
my first good job my college sweetheart
my college town being poor when young
led to making money when old losing
faith in my bosses and elders made me
independent and an adult almost getting
into the wrong marriage helped me
recognize and enter the right one
falling sick made me focus on my health
it goes on and on
inside suffering is the seed of change
if you could have a gigantic billboard
anywhere with anything on it what would
it say and why desire is a contract that
you make with yourself to be unhappy
until you get what you want
desire is a driver a motivator in fact a
sincere and uncompromising desire placed
above everything else is nearly always
fulfilled but every judgement every
preference every setback spawns its own
desire and soon we drown in them each
one a problem to be solved and we suffer
until it's fulfilled happiness or at
least peace is the sense that nothing is
missing in this moment no desires
running amok it's okay to have a desire
but pick a big one and pick it carefully
drop the small ones
what is one of the best or most
worthwhile investments you've ever made
every book I read that wasn't assigned
to me or that I didn't read with a
purpose in mind the genuine love for
reading itself when cultivated is a
superpower we live in the age of
Alexandria when every book and every
piece of knowledge ever written down is
a fingertip away the means of learning
are abundant it's the desire to learn
that's scarce cultivate that desire by
reading what you want not what your
- in the last five years what new belief
behavior or habit has most improved your
life happiness is a choice you make and
a skill you develop the mind is just as
malleable as the body we spend so much
time and effort trying to change the
external world other people and our own
bodies all the while accepting ourselves
the way we were programmed in our youths
we accept the voice that talks to us in
our head all the time as the source of
all truth but all of it is malleable
every day is new and memory and identity
are burdens from the past that prevent
us from living freely in the present
what advice would you give to a smart
driven college student about to enter
the real world what advice should they
ignore advice follow your intellectual
curiosity over whatever is hot right now
if your curiosity ever leads you to a
place where society eventually wants to
go you'll get paid extremely well do
everything you were going to do but with
less angst less suffering less emotion
everything takes time ignore the news
complainers angry people high conflict
people anyone trying to scare you about
a danger that isn't clear and present
don't do things that you know are
morally wrong not because someone is
watching but because you are self-esteem
is just the reputation that you have
with yourself you'll always know ignore
the unfairness there is no fair play the
hand that you're dealt to the best of
your ability people are highly
consistent so you will eventually get
what you deserve and so will they in the
end everyone gets the same judgment
death
what are bad recommendations you hear in
your profession or area of expertise
you're too young
most of his
was built by young people they just got
credit when they were older the only way
to truly learn something is by doing it
yes listen to guidance but don't wait in
the last five years what have you become
better at saying no to I say no to
nearly everything I make a lot fewer
short-term compromises I aspire to only
work with people who I can work with
forever to invest my time in activities
that are a joy unto themselves and to
focus on the extremely long term so I
have no time for short-term things
dinners with people I won't see again
tedious ceremonies to please tedious
people traveling to places that I
wouldn't go to on vacation when you feel
overwhelmed or unfocused what do you do
memento mori remember that you have to
die all of this will go to nothing
remember before you were born just like
that it all happened so suddenly and
cinematically that it might if I
believed I remembered that actually I
had always wanted to be a writer so I
started writing that very evening
Susan Kane Twitter at Susan Kane
facebook forward slash author Susan Kane
quiet rev.com Susan Cain is the
co-founder of quiet revolution and the
author of the bestsellers quiet power
the secret strengths of introverted kids
and quiet the power of introverts in a
world that can't stop talking which has
been translated into 40 languages and
been on the New York Times bestseller
list for more than four years quiet has
been named the best book of the Year by
Fast Company magazine which also named
Susan one of its most creative people in
business
Susan is the co-founder of the quiet
schools Network and the quiet Leadership
Institute and her writing has appeared
in the New York Times the Atlantic The
Wall Street Journal and other
publications her TED talk has been
viewed more than 17 million times and
was named by Bill Gates as one of his
all-time favorite talks how has a
failure or a parent failure set you up
for later success do you have a favorite
failure of yours many many moons ago I
used to be a corporate lawyer I was an
ambivalent corporate lawyer at best and
anyone could have told you that I was in
the wrong profession but still I
dedicated tons of time three years of
law school one year of clerking for a
federal judge and six and a half years
at a Wall Street firm to be exact and
had lots of deep and treasured
relationships with fellow attorneys but
the day came when I was well along on
partnership track that the senior
partner in my firm came to my office and
told me that I wouldn't be put up for
partner on schedule to this day I don't
know whether he meant that I would never
be put up for partner or just delayed
for a good long while all I know is that
I embarrassingly burst into tears right
in front of him and then asked for a
leave of absence I left work that very
afternoon and bicycle drowned and round
Central Park in New York City having no
idea what to do next I thought I'd
travel I thought I'd stare at the walls
for a while instead and it all happened
so suddenly and cinematically that it
might defy belief I remembered that
actually I had always wanted to be a
writer so I started writing that very
evening the next day I signed up for a
class at NYU and creative nonfiction
writing and the next week I attended the
first session of class and knew that I
was finally home I had no expectation of
ever making a living through writing but
it was crystal clear to me that from
then on writing would be my Center and
that I would look for freelance work
that would give me lots of free time to
pursue it if I had succeeded at making
partner right on schedule
I might still be miserably negotiating
corporate transactions
eighteen hours a day it's not that I'd
never thought about what else I might
like to do other than law but until I
had the time and space to think about
life outside the Hermetic culture of a
law practice I couldn't figure out what
I really wanted to do what is one of the
best or most worthwhile investments
you've ever made seven years of time to
write quiet I didn't care how long it
took and though I wanted the book to
succeed I felt good about the investment
of time regardless of the outcome
because I felt so certain that writing
in general and writing that book in
particular was the right thing to do I
handed in a first draft after the first
two years which my editor correctly
pronounced crappy she put it only
slightly more delicately
she said take all the time you need
start from scratch and get it right I
left her office elated because I agreed
with her I knew that I needed years to
get it right after all I'd never
published a thing before quiet so I was
learning how to write a book from
scratch and I was thrilled that she was
giving me the time most publishing
houses rush books to market long before
they're fully baked if she'd done that
there would be no quiet revolution what
is an unusual habit or an absurd thing
that you love I love sad minor-key music
I find it elevating and transcendent and
not really sad at all I think that's
because this kind of music is really
about the fragility and therefore the
preciousness of life and love Leonard
Cohen is my patron saint try dance me to
the end of love or famous blue raincoat
or pretty much anything else he's ever
written including of course hallelujah
his best-known song but really only the
tip of the Leonard iceberg also hinako
feh you are beautiful by edon oh hell
it's a gorgeous song of longing for the
beloved but really it's about longing in
general my favorite word in any language
is saudade the Portuguese word that's at
the heart of Brazilian and Portuguese
culture and music it means
roughly a sweet longing for a beloved
thing or person that will likely never
return
try the music of mod radio sources Aria
Evora my next book is sort of on this
topic what advice would you give to a
smart driven college students about to
enter the real world what advice should
they ignore you will hear so many
stories of people who risked everything
in order to achieve this or that goal
especially creative goals but I do not
believe that your best creative work is
done when you're stressed out because
you're teetering on the edge of
bankruptcy or other personal disasters
just the opposite you should set up your
life so that it is as comfortable and
happy as possible and so that it
accommodates your creative work I often
ask myself whether all those years of
Wall Street law were a waste
given that what I was really meant to do
the whole time was to explore human
psychology and to tell the truth in
writing about what it's like to be alive
and the answer is no it wasn't a waste
for many reasons first because I learned
so much about the so-called real world
that would have otherwise remained a
permanent mystery second because a
front-row seat at a Wall Street
negotiation is as good a place as any to
study the occasional ridiculousness of
humans but finally because it gave me a
financial cushion when I was ready to
try a creative light it wasn't a huge
cushion as I hadn't saved that much but
it made a huge difference even once I
started my writing life I spent tons of
time setting up a modest freelance
business teaching people negotiation
skills that I could use to support
myself for as long as it took I told
myself that my writing goal was to get
something published by the time I was 75
years old I wanted writing to be a
permanent source of pleasure and never
be associated with financial stress or
more generally the pressure to achieve
of course I'm not saying that the smart
driven college student in your question
should spend ten years in finance before
striking out creatively but they should
be planning on how they're going to make
ends meet that way the time that they do
spur
with their creative projects whether
it's 30 minutes or 10 hours a day can be
all about focus flow and occasional
glimpses of joy when you feel
overwhelmed or unfocused
what do you do I love espresso and would
happily consume it all day but I only
allow myself one latte a day and save it
for what I'm doing my creative work
partly because it jump-starts my mind
almost magically and partly because this
has trained me Pavlovian style to
associate writing with the pleasure of
coffee it is likely that most of what
you currently learn at school will be
irrelevant by the time you were 40 my
best advice is to focus on personal
resilience and emotional intelligence
you've all know a Harare twitter at
Harare underscore you've all facebook
tim dot blog /her re - Facebook redirect
why in Harare comm you've all know a
Harare is the author of the
international bestseller z-- sapiens a
brief history of humankind and homo Deus
a brief history of tomorrow he received
his PhD from the University of Oxford in
2002 and is now a lecturer in the
Department of History at the Hebrew
University of Jerusalem
Yuval has twice won the Polanski prize
for creativity and originality in 2009
and 2012 he has published numerous
articles including armchairs coffee and
authority eyewitnesses and flesh
witnesses speak about war 1,100 to 2,000
for which he won the Society from
military histories man condo award his
current research focuses on macro
historical questions what is the
relation between history and biology
what is the essential difference between
Homo sapiens and other animals is there
justice in history just history have a
direct
did people become happier as history
unfolded what is the book or books
you've given most as a gift and why or
what are one two three books that have
greatly influenced your life Aldous
Huxley's brave new world I think it is
the most prophetic book of the 20th
century and the most profound discussion
of happiness in modern Western
philosophy it had a deep impact on my
thinking about politics and happiness
and since for me the relationship
between power and happiness is the most
important question in history brave new
world has also reshaped my understanding
of history Huxley wrote the book in 1931
with communism and fascism entrenched in
Russia and Italy Nazism on the rise in
Germany militaristic Japan embarking on
its war of conquest in China and the
entire world gripped by the Great
Depression yet Huxley managed to see
through all these dark clouds and
envision a future society without wars
famines and plagues enjoying
uninterrupted peace abundance and health
it is a consumerist world which gives
completely free rein to sex drugs and
rock and roll and whose supreme value is
happiness it uses advanced biotechnology
and social engineering to make sure that
everyone is always content and no one
has any reason to rebel there is no need
of a secret police concentration camps
or a Ministry of love Allah Orwell's
1984 indeed
Huxley's genius consists in showing that
you could control people far more
securely through love and pleasure than
through violence and fear when people
read George Orwell's 1984 it is clear
that he is describing a frightening
nightmare world and the only question
left open is how do we avoid reaching
such a terrible state reading brave new
world is a far more disconcerting
experience because it is
obvious that there must be something
dreadfully wrong but you are hard
pressed to put your finger on it
the world is peaceful and prosperous and
everyone is supremely satisfied all the
time what could possibly be wrong with
that the truly amazing thing is that
when Huxley wrote brave new worlds back
in 1931 both he and his readers knew
perfectly well that he was describing a
dangerous dystopia yet many readers
today might easily mistake it for a
utopia our consumerist society is
actually geared to realizing Huxley's
vision today happiness has become the
supreme value and we increasingly used
biotechnology and social engineering to
ensure maximum satisfaction to all
citizen customers you want to know what
could be wrong with that
read the dialogue between Mustapha Mond
the world controller for Western Europe
and John the savage who lived all his
life on a native reservation in New
Mexico and who is the only man in London
who still knows anything about
Shakespeare or God what is an unusual
habit or an absurd thing that you love
when going on an elevator or escalator
trying to stand on the tips of my toes
how has a failure or apparent failure
set you up for later success do you have
a favorite failure of yours after I
published sapiens in Hebrew and it
became a best-seller in Israel I thought
it would be easy to publish an English
translation of it I translated it and
sent it to various publishers but all
rejected it out of hand I still preserve
a particularly humiliating rejection
letter I got from one very prominent
publishing house so I then tried to self
publish it on Amazon the quality was
quite dreadful and it sold just a couple
of hundred copies I was very frustrated
for some time then I realized that the
DIY meth
just doesn't work and that instead of
looking for shortcuts I needed to do it
the hard and long way and rely on
professional help my husband Itzik who
is a far better businessman than me took
over he found us a wonderful literary
agent Deborah Harris whose advice led us
to hire an outstanding editor Haim
watzmann who helped me rewrite and
polish the text with their assistance we
got a contract from Harvill Secker a
division of Random House my editor there
Michael shove it turned the text into a
real gem and hired the best independent
PR agency in the UK book market riot
communications to do the PR campaign I
make a point of mentioning their names
because it was only thanks to the
professional work of all these experts
that sapience became an international
bestseller without them it would have
remained an unknown rough diamond like
so many other excellent books that
nobody has heard about from the initial
failure I learned the limits of my own
abilities and the importance of going to
the experts instead of looking for
shortcuts what advice would you give to
a smart driven college student about to
enter the real world what advice should
they ignore nobody really knows what the
world and the job market will look like
in 2040 hence nobody knows what to teach
young people today consequently it is
likely that most of what you currently
learn at school will be irrelevant by
the time you are 40 so what should you
focus on my best advice is to focus on
personal resilience and emotional
intelligence
traditionally life has been divided into
two main parts a period of learning
followed by a period of working in the
first part of life you built a stable
identity and acquired personal and
professional skills in the second part
of life you relied on your identity and
skills to navigate the world earn a
living and contribute to
xiety by 2040 this traditional model
will become obsolete and the only way
for humans to stay in the game will be
to keep learning throughout their lives
and to reinvent themselves again and
again the world of 2040 will be a very
different world from today and an
extremely hectic world the pace of
change is likely to accelerate even
further so people will need the ability
to learn all the time and to reinvent
themselves repeatedly even at age 60 yet
change is usually stressful and after a
certain age most people don't like to
change when you are 16 your entire life
is change whether you like it or not
your body is changing your mind is
changing your relationships are changing
everything is in flux
you are busy inventing yourself by the
time you were 40 you don't want change
you want stability but in the 21st
century you won't be able to enjoy that
luxury if you try to hold on to some
stable identity some stable job some
stable worldview you will be left behind
and the world will fly by you so people
will need to be extremely resilient and
emotionally balanced to sail through
this never-ending storm and to deal with
very high levels of stress the problem
is that it is very hard to teach
emotional intelligence and resilience it
is not something you can learn by
reading a book or listening to a lecture
the current educational model devised
during the 19th century Industrial
Revolution is bankrupt but so far we
haven't created a viable alternative so
don't trust the adults too much in the
past it was a safe bet to trust adults
because they knew the world quite well
and the world changed slowly but the
21st century is going to be different
whatever the adults have learned about
economics
tics or relationships maybe outdated
similarly don't trust technology too
much you must make technology serve you
instead of use serving it if you aren't
careful technology will start dictating
your aims and enslaving you to its
agenda so you have no choice but to
really get to know yourself better know
who you are and what you really want
from life this is of course the oldest
advice in the book know thyself but this
advice has never been more urgent than
in the 21st century because now you have
competition Google Facebook Amazon and
the government are all relying on big
data and machine learning to get to know
you better and better we are not living
in the era of hacking computers we are
living in the era of hacking humans once
the corporations and governments know
you better than you know yourself
they could control and manipulate you
and you won't even realize it so if you
want to stay in the game you have to run
faster than Google good luck in the last
five years what have you become better
at saying no to what new realizations
and or approaches helped I have become
much better at saying no to invitations
which is a matter of survival because I
get dozens of invitations a week to tell
the truth though I'm still quite lousy
at refusing I feel so bad saying no so I
outsource tit my husband who is much
better not only at business but also at
refusing does most of the hard work for
me and now we hired an assistant who
spends hours every day just refusing
people what is one of the best or most
worthwhile investments you've ever made
by far the best investment of time I
ever made was to do a 10-day Vipassana
meditation wwu org retreat as a teenager
and later as a student
I was a very troubled and restless
person the world made no sense to me and
I got no answers to the big questions I
had about life in particular I didn't
understand why there was so much
suffering in the world and in my own
life and what could be done about it all
I got from the people around me and from
the books I read were elaborate fictions
religious myths about gods and heavens
nationalist myths about the motherland
and its historical mission romantic
myths about love and adventure or
capitalist myths about economic growth
and how buying and consuming stuff will
make me happy I had enough sense to
realize that these were probably all
fictions but I had no idea how to find
the truth while I was doing my doctorate
at Oxford a good friend nagged me for a
year to try a veep asana meditation
course I thought it was some new-age
mumbo-jumbo and since I had no interest
in hearing yet another mythology I
declined to go but after a year of
patient nudging he got me to give it a
chance previously I knew very little
about meditation and presumed it must
involve all kinds of complicated
mystical theories I was therefore amazed
by how practical the teaching turned out
to be the feature at the course SN gonca
instructed the students to sit with
crossed legs and closed eyes and to
focus all their attention on the breath
coming in and out of their nostrils
don't do anything
he kept saying don't try to control the
breath or to breathe in any particular
way just observe the reality of the
present moment whatever it may be when
the breath comes in you just know now
the breath is coming in when the breath
goes out you just know now the breath is
going out and when you lose your focus
and your mind starts wandering in
memories and fantasies you just know now
my mind has wandered away from the
breath
it was the most
important thing anybody has ever told me
the first thing I learned by observing
my breath was that notwithstanding all
the books I had read and all the classes
I had attended at university I knew
almost nothing about my mind and I had
very little control over it despite my
best efforts I couldn't observe the
reality of my breath coming in and out
of my nostrils for more than 10 seconds
before the mind wandered away for years
I lived under the impression that I was
the master of my life and the CEO of my
own personal brand but a few hours of
meditation were enough to show me that I
hardly had any control of myself I was
not the CEO I was barely the gatekeeper
I was asked to stand at the gateway of
my body the nostrils and just observe
whatever comes in or goes out yet after
a few moments I lost my focus and
abandoned my post it was a humbling and
eye-opening experience as the course
progressed students were taught to
observe not just their breath but
sensations throughout their body heat
pressure pain and so forth the technique
of Vipassana
is based on the insight that the flow of
mind is closely interlinked with bodily
sensations between me and the world
there are always bodily sensations and
never react to events in the outside
world I always react to the sensations
in my own body when the sensation is
unpleasant I react with a version when
the sensation is pleasant I react with
craving for more even when we think we
react to what another person had done or
to a distant childhood memory or to the
global financial crisis the truth is we
always react to attention in the
shoulder or a spasm in the pit of the
stomach you want to know what anger is
we'll just observe the sensations that
arise and pass in your body while you
are angry I was 24 years old at the time
I went to this retreat
and had probably experienced anger
10,000 times previously yet I never
bothered to observe how anger actually
felt whenever I was angry I focused on
the object of my anger something
somebody else did or said rather than on
the physical reality of the anger I
think I learned more about myself and
about humans in general by observing my
sensations for those ten days than I
learned in my whole life before and to
do so I didn't have to accept any story
theory or mythology I just had to
observe reality as it is the most
important thing I realized was that the
deep source of my suffering is in the
patterns of my own mind when I want
something and it doesn't happen my mind
reacts by generating suffering suffering
is not an objective condition in the
outside world it is a mental reaction
generated by my own mind since that
first course in 2000 I began practicing
veep asana for two hours every day and
each year I take a long meditation
retreat for a month or two it is not an
escape from reality it is getting in
touch with reality at least for two
hours a day I actually observe reality
as it is while for the other 22 hours I
get overwhelmed by emails and tweets and
funny cat videos without the focus and
clarity provided by this practice I
could not have written sapiens and Homo
Deus when you feel overwhelmed or
unfocused what do you do
I observe my breath for a few seconds or
minutes hey guys this is Tim again just
a few more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet Friday do
you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in with your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
[Applause]